we're moving on to Syria we're
anti-government protests have erupted in
the southern city of sueda a protester
and a policeman were killed by gunfire
after demonstrators stormed the
governor's building more than 200 people
gathered outside to protest against
economic hardship and called for
president Bashar al-assad to step down
let's bring in Christine hillberg she's
a freelance journalist and Middle East
analyst who specializes in Sierra
mattelburgh welcome tell us what are
these protests about
well they are about Rising prices power
Cuts food shortages fuel shortages the
electricity rationing that the regime
has just put in place so there is an
econ economic decline for years in Syria
and this economic hardship obviously has
severe impact on the daily life of the
syrians everywhere in the country we
have 90 of the people in Syria living
below the poverty line 12.4 million
don't have enough to eat they very much
rely on the food baskets and other
humanitarian Aid that is being provided
by the United Nations Finance basically
by Western countries like the US and
Germany and the EU so people are angry
they are hopeless they are desperate and
in Sweda it seems that they have the
courage to bring this anger to the
streets
the Sweda region though is the heartland
of the Drew's community and they've
largely kept out of the country's
long-running Civil War could this be
about to change
well there has been some local protests
before in Sweden they are very rare in
other places of of Syria but in Sweda we
have a special situation because the the
religious minority of the Jews has
managed with difficulty to stay neutral
throughout the years of the war in Syria
the province has always been under
regime control but the regime has
conceded some influence to the local
Drew's leadership the political and the
religious leaderships so these people
managed to balance a little bit the
position the Drew's Community for
example has its own militias in Sweda so
the young man from Sweda can avoid being
conscripted to Assad's Army and join
their own militias to be able to defend
their Hometown Hometown and their
historical Homeland so this gives them
the courage to confront the regime Which
is less powerful in Sweden than in other
places in Syria for example Damascus or
homs or Aleppo how nervously is their
regime watching this
Assad's power is built on fear and it's
built on the brutal force of the
security apparatus so people are being
afraid of being detained and tortured so
if the suffering now gets so bad that
people don't mind being killed then this
really could turn into a problem for
Assad and there's an interesting point
here because if you look at the
demonstrators now in Sweda they are in
the majority under 30 years old which
means that they were children during the
time of the revolution of 2011. so these
people carry on the Legacy by chanting
the same slogans taking down the
pictures of bashal Assad like we saw in
2011 2012 so this new generation knows
nothing but war and they as well blame
the regime and they hold as her
personally responsible for his failure
to resolve the economic crisis so this
means that the protests can repeat
themselves any time and the revolution
might not be over and it might even be
passed on to a Next Generation do you
think we'll see these protests spread
it could happen in other parts of the
South especially as I said the regime's
grip on power is very strong in Damascus
it's very strong in the coastal region
in Aleppo in in Hans so the fear is
still too big for people to rise in
large numbers but we see that the
suffering is really getting people
becoming very frustrated and I mean the
presidential couple itself concentrated
the economic power in its own hands
which means that they even alienated
some people of the business within the
business Elite if we talk to businessmen
in Damascus or Aleppo who are or used to
be strong allies of the regime they even
feel uh you know pressured because this
regime tries to press
um money out of them you know they are
they have to pay high taxes now and this
brings them obviously to a point when
they say okay we cannot stand with this
regime anymore so this is a dangerous
game Bashar Assad and his wife are just
trying to use these people they have cut
ties even within their own family so
they're very much concentrated the power
to their own very Inner Circle
themselves the presidential couple and
this could be dangerous because they are
really losing a lot of people who kept
them in power over the last 12 years
journalist Kristen halberg pleasure
speaking to you tonight
thank you